wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
und ich könnte nach der ausbildung
wirklich bei dir arbeiten ja das ist
mein angebot
doom ist dass es nur wollen und du bist
das dafür arbeiten
ok ich will es also wie geht's los leute
zuerst musst du deine spanischen zeugnis
versetzen lassen
sobald du einen platz an der
berufsschule hast kannst du mit
ausbildung beginnen und ich kann die
ausbildung wirklich bei dir machen ja
ein fahrradladen ist ein meisterbetrieb
ich darf auch ausbilden und ich wäre
nach drei jahren mit der ausbildung
fertig genau und ich hätte einen top
mitarbeiter gut muss ich bei der
übersetzung die zeugnisse irgendwas
beachten ich meine sind die deutschen
und schulabschlüsse anders aus die in
spanien etwas anders schon es gibt den
hauptschulabschluss den
realschulabschluss und das abitur das
kannst du auf dem gymnasium machen aber
ich könnte mit neuen spanischen
abschluss hier studieren
das ist kein problem aber fragt jemand
noch mal nach ok ich erkundige mich hab
das mit meinem spanischen abschluss
funktioniert hier steht noch dass ich
einen nachweis über meine
deutschkenntnisse brauchen du müsstest
die b1 prüfung machen dann muss ich auf
jeden fall noch eine menge lernen
glaubst du kannst das schafft auf jeden
fall
ich bin stolz auf dich